what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four so let's just get right
into it man because do the ending of the
story
it's like it's like one of the greatest
moments ever in the history of Marvel
Comics check this out so what this
initially does is it picks up with the
Future Foundation the reason why the art
looks like this is because the story is
designed to be told from a child's
perspective so the art reflects a kind
of childlike art now one of the things
that you guys may recall is that in the
previous stories that we did regarding
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four that
what had happened is the cree had
invaded Earth they had launched attack
against Earth while that was happening
the forces of annihilus were basically
launching their attack in order to allow
the annihilation wave to enter in from
the negative zone so there was a
multi-pronged strike albeit that both
forces were unaware of the other but the
kicker about all this is that Valeria
Richards did exactly what she was
supposed to do which was hit the panic
button and teleport the Future
Foundation for the Baxter building to a
safe location which turns out to be
latviria where doctor Dooms at but the
thing about this is that with this
meeting here you have this conversation
between Valeria and Nathaniel Richards
the father of Reed now remember
Nathaniel comes from the future but
nobody's supposed to know right no one's
supposed to know he's from the future
Valeria figured it out and she figured
it out because of the fact that she's so
incredibly intelligent so while
Nathaniel thought he was being secretive
Valeria figured out all the clues and so
it's one of those things where she's
like you shouldn't be going around doing
that and he's like why and she's like
because you could screw everything up
temporal anomalies cascading events
collapsing time streams like you should
know all of this stuff you're a time
traveler and he's like well that's not
necessarily exactly how it happens
besides if you knew that and you would
figure that out why did you go and make
a secret deal with Dr Doom and then
she's like well I guess you knew about
that because you're from the future and
he's like no because all hope lies in
Doom Nathaniel says I sent the future
Franklin to you like I'm the one who
sent him to you so that he could have
that conversation and give you that
piece of information so that you could
hold on to it for when it was necessary
to implement that I.E your meeting with
Victor Von Doom and so it's a cool thing
because he asked her do you remember the
rest right the dead must not be
forgotten the the future man must return
to save the past right kind of hitting
at this idea that Nathaniel is the
future man so he tells her this is what
we're going to do and Nathaniel and
Valeria basically form a plan now when
they go and they meet with Christoph
Bernard the adopted son of Doctor Doom
and Dr Doom himself Kristoff is totally
like flabbergasted by this like wait a
minute what is your idea here now of
course you have the alternate version of
Reed Richards who's here kind of the
last surviving member of the Council of
reads the ones that sort of initiated
all of this in the first place and again
it's one of these things where this guy
has control of Dr deer now remember he
slapped the collar around Dr Doom's neck
so that if Dr Doom disobeys what this
alternate version of Reed tells him kill
a bottom eyes doom on the spot right
like instantaneously he'll take him out
the reality here and what they intend to
do is to go back to the bridge to
basically reopen the bridge and then
face off against the mad celestials and
find a way to destroy them right to
defeat the mad celestials so they never
arrive on Earth because remember all of
this is because of Reed that you had the
Council of reads and you have read
Richards himself the main Marvel
Universe Reed opened the portal the
Council of reeds greeted him and then he
traveled with the council and learned
there's basically this group of Reed
Richards across the Multiverse who
abandoned their families that what they
did is they solved problems across the
Multiverse they turned entire like
universes into nothing more than just
crop farms where they grow food for
other universes to like feed whole other
universes like that's their thing but
one of those versions of Reed Drew the
attention of a universe's version of the
celestials who'd gone crazy with power
and forced everybody to worship them as
Gods once they became aware of that read
and by extension a portal that would
grant them access to the Multiverse they
did what anybody with extreme levels of
power and no real checks and balances
would do they tried to expand that
sphere of influence that's what led to
the fight with the Council of reeds and
that is why we're where we are right now
is because of Reed opening the portal
and meeting with the council in the
first place now we are going to get a
little more information about this but
one of the things Valeria does is she
sneaks into the vault and she basically
takes the ultimate nullifier now for
those of you guys who don't know about
this this thing is nuts the ultimate
nullifier is one of the most powerful
weapons in existence and in fact
Jonathan Hickman is going to clarify the
ultimate nullifier to a degree but the
nullifier is an object a device that if
you use it and you Channel it at
somebody you can wipe them from
existence as if they never existed in
the first place it's crazy right it's
just one of the most Bonkers things ever
in Marvel Comics but the thing about
this is that once they get to the bridge
they ultimately activate it and they're
like it's time to go in right it's time
to enter this and see what's on the
other side because the last time they
were there the Reeds were fleeing for
their lives right like they were just
running to escape death from the Mad
celestials who were annihilating
everything now once they get in there
the Mad celestials are still there right
they're still present now here's the
thing to understand right you might be
asking yourself because for I guess you
could call it our time like months have
passed like maybe almost a year has
passed so the question you have to ask
yourself is have these these celestials
just been sitting there like just
standing there for like months months
maybe even a year the answer is yes and
no when it comes to this place right the
Council of reads it exists outside of
space and time so time doesn't apply
here so as far as the natural mad
celestials are here like these guys
basically ran through a second ago and
just came back out again right like no
real time has passed that's how things
work here and that's why they've been
there this entire time but the crazy
thing about this is that what it does is
it jumps back to the meeting with
valyria and Nathaniel and the two of
them are kind of talking about
everything that's going on and what's
Happening Here is they're talking about
something called catastrophe theory that
the way that it's explained by Nathaniel
is a series of ever worsening ruinous
events that individually represent a
system-wide threat but when combined
constitutes a permanent obliteration of
said system the system in this case is
all of mankind that what we're looking
at here right the things that are taking
place here the annihilation wave
entering into The Fray after being
released the cree launching their attack
against earth when Black Bolt basically
escaped the fault and essentially the
Supreme intelligence realized a black
ball humans were still alive and wanted
to wipe out the rest of the Inhumans
Reed going through the gate all that
kind of stuff the war of the four cities
everything just keeps getting worse and
worse and worse and worse and is all
pointing to the complete and total
obliteration of all of humanity now of
course this leads to the most logical
question right like Valeria says I don't
mean to be disrespectful but is it
possible there are some holes in your
theory and Nathaniel asked how so and
she says well why don't we just work to
prevent one of the earlier bad things
and he interprets that to her saying you
mean stop the cascading nature of the
event before it begins I.E stop read
Richards from going through the gate and
the response to Nathaniel is that cannot
be done there are some things that
happen in this universe and in every
universe that are constants they always
take place there was no preventing the
Return of Black Bull and there was no
preventing the cree race from realizing
Black Bolt had returned that the
Inhumans still existed in the universe
and trying to destroy them the war
between the cree and the Inhumans would
always lead to the extermination of
Earth it's inevitable and the only way
that war can be held at Bay is by Johnny
Storm's Annihilation wave the reasons
for it happening will vary they won't
always be the same but in every single
Universe across the Multiverse at some
point in time the possibility of a Dying
Earth will spark the return of Galactus
and the Mad celestials will attempt to
destroy the universe as it holds the
last read from the of the Council of
reeds from them right everything else
the creation of the Future Foundation
the war of the four cities all of these
things have only created more favorable
conditions to do what must be done and
that's the kicker here right those are
all absolute things these things always
happen that there's no avoiding it and
so that's when Valeria asked then like
what's the best we can hope for and the
response of Nathaniel is to spread these
events out right to to ensure that like
the invasion of the annihilation wave
and the attack of the creek and their
war with the Inhumans and Galactus and
the mad celestials that it all just
doesn't happen back to back to back to
back to like all at one time right
because in every other timeline that's
seemingly when it happened it all
happened at once the cree launched their
attack on Earth and went to war with the
Inhumans as Galactus showed up when the
Mad celestials arrived like it would
always lead to the destruction of all of
Earth and everybody on it that always
seems to happen now this is one of the
cool things about that is because what
we end up doing is jumping back to where
everybody else is Right jumping back to
like the bridge or to the Council of
Reed Citadel whatever you want to call
it and the battle with the mad
celestials now initially they won't let
Dr Doom do his thing this alternate
version of read right the last survivor
of the Council of reads outside of the
main Marvel universe that this guy
believes that he can take all of this on
his own but the response of valyria is
no you have to let Doctor Doom go this
is the reason why she took the ultimate
nullifier because she needed a backup
plan she wanted to make sure this
version of read would do exactly what
she told him to remember all hope lies
and doom if Doom has an inhibitor collar
around his neck and at any given moment
he could just be lobotomized there ain't
a whole lot of Hope there but like if
Doctor Doom is completely freed and he's
allowed to do whatever ever it is that
he needs to do then all hope lies in
Doom hence the reason for the for the
nullify so once that's done and Dr Doom
is freed from his control then it's on
like Donkey Kong because one of the
coolest things that goes on here is we
switch to Franklin little Franklin
Richards this little kid now I told you
guys Franklin Richards is powerful he's
ridiculously op and he always has been
the funny thing about this is he doesn't
know how powerful he is so what he says
as he's talking to his friend leech is
he says it's weird I can hear them
thinking and I think they're sick or
something like what should we do so
Franklin goes and talks to the mad
celestials now when they analyze him
what they realize is just how powerful
Franklin is Franklin Richards could
annihilate these guys that's exactly
that's exactly Their Fear and their
concern now this is how powerful
Franklin is that literally they try to
blast Franklin Richards with energy he
basically blocks it and then the energy
turns to flowers and he was like why do
you guys have flowers growing out of
your head literally he altered reality
so that their attack was useless Not
only was their attack useless it turned
him to something arbitrary but here's
the big thing behind this and this is
why I say guys like mad gym Jaspers are
really really powerful because again
also reality but he has nothing on
Franklin Richards Franklin Richards is
outside of all Universal space he's
outside of space and time he's literally
in this Citadel the rules and the laws
of physics do not apply here so he
literally is just a living embodiment of
a god-like being now the other part
about this is that the celestials
realizing how powerful he is decide to
attack his Consciousness and what they
tell him is that you Franklin Richards
are so powerful that you will live to
see the end of the universe when that
time comes we don't know what will
happen but you will outlive all things
in existence if you choose to right the
downside to this is you will outlive
everyone you know and love and those
individuals who do know you will learn
to hate you because of the fact that
you're so powerful and you're not bound
by age it's just going to be a
fundamental part of who you are now we
know that to be the case partly because
of another video that we're going to do
with Jonathan Miss Fantastic Four after
uh Rob you're probably here in the next
couple weeks but also because of like a
history of the Marvel universe that
comic book line that Marvel wrote
because of my awesome series that I made
that in turn establishes that Galactus
and Franklin will be the two last living
things in existence at least that was
the case until we got Al Ewing's into
structure or what is an immortal Hulk
when basically the one below all kills
everything in existence and then kills
Franklin and kills Galactus and then
just absorbs their power and lives on in
the next universe and then kills
everything there but the important thing
here is that in this moment when
Franklin's able to fight the celestials
off they fire off a few of their fingers
which in turn are able to kind of hold
the portal open now the thing about this
is that while it does lead to the rest
of the Future Foundation basically
vacating and getting out as fast as they
can that you have this conversation
between Valeria and Doctor Doom now
there is something that's said here
right there is a very important thing to
said here we won't find out what it is
right now instead Doctor Doom tells her
get out of here I will basically do what
I can and I will hold these guys off now
she's like how do you know that you'll
survive like how do you know that you'll
make it and the response of Doom is
because I am doomed destroyer of worlds
what gods DARE stand against me right
who would be so foolish as to challenge
the power of Dr Doom which is just like
a ridiculously amazing moment now the
reality here is that jumping back to the
meeting that happened with Nathaniel and
Valeria they kind of go to like this
sort of abandoned Citadel and they have
this really really cool conversation now
the way this plays out is that they're
basically looking at the series of
events as they've happened and what
Nathaniel says is a thing is going to
happen soon and when it does that will
be our Saving Grace that's our Ace in
the Hole that's the means by which we
will survive all of this the problem is
by the time all this stuff happens right
everything going on with like the mad
celestials and all of that if we don't
buy time then we're going to be dead by
the time that thing happens and when
that thing happens it'll be too late to
save any of us so you have to find a way
to buy US 27 minutes full area you have
to find a way to make that happen that's
the reason why Dr Doom is basically
staying behind that's a cool thing that
goes on here here is because one of the
things that takes place is you basically
move or transition over to Doctor Doom
and that alternate version of read who
are facing off against the mad
celestials now they're doing what they
can but the funny thing is that in order
for Doctor Doom to be freed by that
version of read that version of read
demanded the ultimate nullifier which
was given to him by Valeria Richards and
so what he does is in channeling the
ultimate nullifier we end up getting the
caveat that goes along with this that
what Jonathan Hickman does is transition
us back to the Council of reads when
that version of Reed had attained the
ultimate nullifier and he was warned by
the other members in the council that
thing will kill anybody who uses it but
one of the Reeds chimes in and says
that's actually not true it's a myth
that's a nullifier while being the most
powerful weapon in the universe will
always destroy the person using it it
can be used the device requires complete
focus and alignment of mind and purpose
if you fail to have that it will destroy
you and that's exactly what happens this
version of read and using the ultimate
nullifier his mind starts to wonder to
what they could have done how they could
have fixed things but because he loses
his Focus he's destroyed by the ultimate
nullifier that he's wielding and the Mad
celestials continue to exist so with Dr
Doom doing what he can against these
guys and literally trying to hold him
off he basically just tells him like do
whatever it is that you feel like you
can do there's nothing you can do that
can destroy me but the funny thing here
is that as the bridge begins to falter
the mad celestials in a moment of dire
just straight attack Dr Doom and he
seemingly holds it off the problem with
this is that as everything seems to wind
down and while it does seem like the day
is saved the portal starts closing off
one of the Mad celestials reaches in and
pulls the portal apart and in doing that
allows the Mad celestials to enter into
the main Marvel universe so at the end
of the last video that we covered when
we talked about the Mad celestials had
arrived this is how they got there right
this is how they arrive there it's
really one of the most important parts
of the story and it's one that we didn't
cover when we originally covered
Hickman's Fantastic Four which I kind of
wish was something that we had done but
following this we pick up with Future
Foundation as they're basically rescued
by the power pack for those of you guys
who don't know who the power pack are
they're not overly important to this
story it's just basically a bunch of
like really young kids operating as
superheroes but the whole thing behind
this is that while you have like
Franklin and the other members of really
the Future Foundation and the power pack
that are making their way towards what
is in effect Saul's Anvil the weapon
that was constructed by those surviving
members of the Council of reeds in order
to destroy the mad celestials it still
exists on Earth but it's lacking the
final power source which is the
annihilation wave right that last piece
of energy that can be used to channel
the whole thing that you have Franklin
just kind of being met by this
disembodied voice and he's ultimately
just like could you be quiet for a
second man like could you shut the hell
up and that's what we end up finding out
that is basically his older self right
Franklin from the future talking to his
younger self and so it's one of those
things where he says have you done what
I asked and Franklin you know young
Franklin says yes I keep it here next to
my heart well the problem is I had to
use some of it if I hadn't done that
then like the Mad celestials would have
killed everybody and his adult self says
well you know you can't help who you are
hopefully it'll still be enough and so
literally his future cell off says it's
almost time and then seemingly
disappears away at that point the Future
Foundation arrives at Saul's Anvil which
can we just say is one of the coolest
names ever for a weapon it's just like
this giant just kind of building Citadel
that can destroy the mad celestials or
at least seems like it can now the
important thing here is that at Saul's
Anvil while they are missing the
annihilation wave as the final power
source Johnny Storm and the Fantastic
Four arrive and because Johnny Storm is
showing up with basically the cosmic
control rod from the Negative Zone which
leaves the annihilation way that's the
power source they need that now Saul's
Anvil can be fired right the funny thing
about this is that as you have young
Franklin walking around with his future
self his future self kind of looks
around and says wow right like the power
of the sun channeled through a fixed
point but trust by the Earth itself
Saul's Anvil is the most powerful weapon
ever constructed solely by man it won't
be enough and as they're looking at all
of this the Mad celestials arrive on the
scene and that's when future Franklin
tells his younger self this is going
going to hurt one bit Now ladies and
gentlemen we switch over to arguably one
of the best moments ever in the history
of Marvel Comics so with the Mad
Celestial is arriving on Earth and with
Galactus arriving around the same time
the Mad celestials traveled to greet
Galactus and as they analyze him they
realize he's a he's a world Devourer
right he's a Galactus that he's not the
first Galactus or the only Galactus
there's a Galactus in every single
Universe around the Multiverse but
they're like Leaf right like this does
not concern you it's not your business
we're here to destroy a world go back
and consume your own worlds and call it
a day and galantis literally says no
right I'm not going anywhere look into
my mind and see that I know your purpose
look there and see that Galactus stands
against you and when Galactus realize
when they realize Galactus knows what
their purpose is which is not silly to
destroy this Earth but to destroy the
entirety of the universe and that
Galactus would stand against all of them
and that if Galactus needed the help he
would seek out the other Cosmic entities
the celestials immediately attack him
right now as soon as that battle pops
off it's real really more than just
anybody can understand it's just beyond
anything like one of the cree soldiers
is talking to the Supreme intelligence
like man what do we do here right we've
got these Cosmic entities who are facing
off against each other just the sheer
amount of radiation they're bleeding off
is more than our ships can handle let
alone if they actually fire off an
attack against one another and that
attack misses and hits us it'll destroy
our ship and that'll be the end of it
Supreme intelligence is like yeah get us
out of here man we got to go and then
you have like black a black ball who
does the only thing that he's ever
useful for which is just like go that
way right run away from the fight
because blackboard's useless like I
can't ever do anything but the thing
about this is that it's it's it's crazy
because Galactus kills one of the
celestials right he kills one of the Mad
celestials destroys this guy in response
to that the remaining mad celestials
merge they combine these guys go full on
Megazord son son right when that happens
they destroy Galactus on the spot they
annihilate right gorgeous dead right
goes falling back down to the Earth
that's the end of him at that point they
turn their sights to like everybody else
on Earth Reed Richards the fantastic for
the Future Foundation right it's drapes
like they come descending down but in
that moment Reed fires off like uses the
energy sources of all those different
areas right the Negative Zone old
Atlantis the blue area of the Moon the
forever City he channels the energy from
all those places into Saul's Anvil and
then combines it with the energy of the
Sun and then fires it off against the
Mad celestials which is not enough to
destroy them but it is enough to break
them apart from their combined form the
problem with Saul's Anvil is twofold one
if they fire it again they can destroy
the world right they could literally
crack the world because they're drawing
energy from the world itself the other
part of that though is it's a risk worth
taking because the alternative is the
Mad celestials are going to kill them
all so in that moment this is why I say
man people are sleeping on Susan's storm
man people don't understand how powerful
season storm is she's like everybody
behind me and just like puts up a force
field and blocks the attack of the mad
celestials at that point like Reed
Richards tells Johnny Storm get as hot
as you possibly can hotter than the sun
with a cosmic control rod he goes flying
in he attacks one of the mad celestials
is enough to damage him but the Mad
Celestial heals then like one of the
other ones attacks Johnny Johnny's out
of the fight so at that point there's no
Cosmic control rod to be used by anybody
now Reed Richards is trying to get
Saul's Anvil back up and running the
weapon system's offline so literally
it's it's curtains it's drapes right
there's there's there's there's no
coming out of this man like the master
Legends are coming down right through
the storms hold up this force field
holding on for dear life right the Mad
celestials break through the force rule
like they all fire at the same time they
destroy the force field and they're like
there's the final interloper right like
Reed Richards will kill him we'll
annihilate the universe and that'll be
the end of it right Susan storm conjures
up kind of like a a force field rod and
like sends it flying through one of
their hands and that's when we hearken
back salsa sauce
that's what we hearken back right to
like the statement that was made when
Valeria from the future came to visit
her mom in the past right and she said
the coming days are going to be dark
dark and full of loss it will feel like
everything is going to fall apart that
it shatter and everything will end only
you can hold us together can you be
strong mother stronger than you've ever
been before and it's one of these crazy
moments because like Susan storm feels
like everything's about to end reads out
of commission Franklin Richards and all
of them are knocked out right like
there's no one left to save them
Galactus is dead this is it it's just
her standing there just laying there
with these mad celestials over top of
her getting ready to annihilate
everything in existence and they're just
like move like move yourself out of the
way move and live we are destroying that
final read and she's like nope that's
not gonna happen but the crazy thing
about this is we kind of get back to
that monologue from her daughter where
she says there will be a moment when
you're going to want to give up you're
going to want to let go when you reach
that point look into the sky look up and
remember the price that was paid and so
on Samsung and one of the best moments
ever Marvel Comics history song reads
like what in the hell is that like
what's that light and Susan's like it's
everything Reed it's our kids that's
right ladies and gentlemen Franklin
Richards from the future has returned he
has arrived in the present and anybody
who knows anything about the Fantastic
Four man I'm telling you right now this
the next video that we do man it's like
the greatest moment ever in the history
of Marvel Comics man I'll leave you all
in this massive ass Cliffhanger thank
you all for watching I will catch you
all later peace